uh thanks a lot for the invitation it's
really a pleasure to be here uh and let
me tell you what this stuff is about
it's going to be really about the use of
semi-definite programming and in
particular uh something called general
speaking semi-definite hierarchies for
promising quantum information
and here's another i mean this is going
to be pretty introductory hopefully if
you have questions you will stop me and
i know you know
and we can clarify those and i really
want to emphasize some of the basic
ideas and results and the intuition i
mean why this kind of things work rather
than perhaps incomprehensible or
overly technical and somehow the kind of
things i want to focus is on just very
shortly at the beginning
at least a geometric viewpoint on
semi-definite optimization which i think
is very very useful
then somehow i'm going to describe uh
shortly at least one motivation to come
into all these hierarchies which is what
happens and as you move on from
quadratic forms to polynomials and we're
going to see immediately how that allows
us to answer questions for instance
about consistency
of moments or questions about for
instance entanglement and separability
and then we'll move on to kind of the
non-commutative versions
because we want to see that somehow it's
exactly the same thing i mean you move
on from commutative to non-commutative
stuff but this formulation of the
semi-definite problems is essentially
the same
so
what's my definite problem i guess we
use it already but i want to again
emphasize a couple of things
you it's really like a generalization of
linear programming into symmetric
matrices so instead of having linear
inequalities in scalar variables now
what i'm going to have is inequalities
in matrix variables or positivity it's
going to mean that things have to be
positive similar
right and i like this geometric picture
of uh
um semi-definite probably i will not
write things in coordinates as much as i
can avoid them and the idea is that but
my definite problem really is it's about
we have the cone of positive
semi-definite matrices we're
intersecting into enough or desert
enough in subspace let me call it l so
my feasible service intersection of this
alpha in subspace and my cone and i'm
minimizing some linear function over
this intersection
so it's really a cone a subspace and i
optimize over this intersection and just
as a comparison if this cone was a
orphaned the non-negative ortho this
would be exactly linear programming but
in here we're changing the conduit with
something which is not perhaps and
somehow many of the same features have
seen will apply although a few things
are going to be scientific
and there's tons of applications i mean
the last 20 years or something that was
really an explosion applications and
semi-definite of semi-definite problems
in many many different areas a
particularly in combinational
optimization control theory and of
course quantum information and say a
little bit about this and why this is
nice again i'm going to abstract out how
do we actually solve it but the reason
why this is nice and convenient is
because it's a nice class of complex
finite dimensional optimization problems
but a little bit more than that i mean
it's not just it's not the kind of
things for instance that we could just
apply the
ellipsoid algorithm a general purpose uh
complex optimization method but there's
a lot of structure in here this is
defined by determinants by we have nice
computable power functions so there's a
lot of things that we can do in here
that parallel very much what we can do
in the linear programming case for
instance there's a beautiful duality
theory that pretty much has exactly the
same features as in linear product and
this is going to come in very useful
we're going to see even in the kind of
things i'm going to describe today that
somehow it's very very convenient to not
just look at your primal formulation of
your optimization problem but you also
want to look at the same time what
happens in the duel and you can carry a
lot of information from one place or the
other and these things are essentially
solved in polynomial
so you
what is the essentially caviar well
essentially caveat has to do depending
exactly on your
so here for instance as opposed to
linear programming in linear programming
if data is rational solutions are
rational and here that's not necessarily
the case
so then
so what you're talking about in here
really has to do with computing epsilon
approximates
and yeah and encoding issues
solutions can be exponentially big
actually
uh
so semibasic problem in quantum
information as i said i know
there's been a lot of applications in
the last 10 15 years these are some
names if your name is not there and it
should be like you know
let's rewind and write it let me know
again
and and most more than anything the only
things i'm going to focus on is a little
bit on some work that we did uh like 10
years ago on an entanglement and
separability and somehow kind of the
corresponding i'm going to use this as a
segway into perhaps one of the things
that i think many of you are kind of
interested which is how do we
characterize a set of quantum
correlations of moments and uh how that
allows me to compute perhaps values of
games
or approximate values of games i should
say
so in the title
we have all these semi-definitions i'll
describe specifically what i mean but
let me perhaps take a step back and try
to discuss at a high level what these
things are actually trying to do and to
me the key the two key features that
these things are trying to do is on the
one hand so of course you're really
trying to approximate some difficult
object that you don't know how to handle
and this could be a set that perhaps
it's non-complex or even if it's convex
it could be like it could be it could be
very computationally difficult to
describe and we're going to see some
examples of that
and somehow the way that these
techniques work or again there's many
many ways of interpreting them but one
in particular i think it's useful is
that essentially what they try to do is
instead of looking at this object
globally what they try to do is they try
to satisfy local consistency conditions
and i write locally here in quotes
because i don't really mean local
uh depending exactly on whether we're
talking about lps or we're talking about
semi-definite programming then we're
talking about some kind of
reviews if you want consistency
conditions and somehow like you know you
know of course there's this or power or
whatever of the blind people they're not
trying to fill an elephant and that's
exactly what happens in here i mean each
constraints that you impose with it will
be a description but there's nothing
that will actually guarantee that all
these things can actually fit together
into uh into a nice global object i mean
if you like topology it's kind of
homology issues
that's right
um
and again we want to see exactly how
these kind of things appear this is not
a formal definition but somehow i really
want to emphasize that there's kind of
these two things i mean on the one hand
uh how do we deal with approximation of
sets and the way that we actually do
this is by by somehow imposing some kind
of low dimensional consistency
conditions of a certain type
so this is something that i mean at
least in spirit it appears all over the
place in particular in optimization
we've been doing this for like 50 years
or something in different versions we of
course now we have a much more
sophisticated way hopefully of thinking
about the things but for instance when
this idea of approximating convex sets
using linear problems linear problems of
a particular type i mean people have
used things called linearization
reformation rough duality shiraeli adams
relaxations all the time and those
produce somehow polyhedral
approximations of complex sets that they
have nice properties and there's a lot
of philosophically related ideas in a
number of areas i mean if you like
probability the idea of locally
consistent margins you have a joint
called distribution between many
variables and perhaps along every subset
things are consistent but there may not
be a global object right and there's a
number of other areas where the kind of
the same kind of things is true
so one thing at this level even
yeah sorry
i should think of the hierarchy as
going less and less local or
less and less local exactly i will it
will become clear later yeah but
essentially you're imposing more
stronger and stronger conditions that
hopefully will bring you closer to the
existence of a global object
right so if you want if you like lp for
instance and you want to understand a
little bit what's the difference between
the kind of things that we did before
with lp and the kind of things that you
can do with semi-defined programming
think about lps imposing again in
particular situations as imposing
consistency conditions between subsets
right so we may impose if we have a
joint probability distribution for
instance that whenever i restrict this
joint this candidate john paul
institution towards subsets some of what
i see is actually consistent
semi-definite firming will do something
different they will say that on every
subspace
things will have to be consistent and of
course you could pick subsets that are
in subspaces that are aligned with
coordinates some subspaces of a form one
one one and all zeros but there's a lot
of other subspaces and somehow some
magnetic product is going to be very
strong in the or much stronger an np in
that sense because it's going to imposes
stronger consistent conditions rather
than just about substance
sorry even linear subspaces yeah linear
subservices so why do there are some
cases you couldn't
formulate with you because you have an
infinitely many subspaces
right when you look at subsidies of
fixed cardinality you have cardinal
decay you're having just k if you look
at all possible subspaces you have an
infinite number
something that doesn't fit into finite
dimensional b
it's really infinite number of
constraints and that's exactly it's a
minor head problem
so what's nice about this is that we
have very compact ways of describing
these things
as we're going to see somehow in a sense
at least i mean of course that's in the
eye of the beholder i think the
semi-dating picture is much easier than
the
you know somehow the healthy picture
because everything becomes linear
algebra instead of combinatorics so
somehow of course depending on your
taste if you like combinatorics then i
know you love this kind of things but
somehow linear algebra at least it's a
lot easier
for at least certain things you have a
lot more symmetries actually that makes
things very very nice
okay so let me start perhaps
i mean there's no technical content in
here but anyway if there's any question
or
yeah
okay so let me start with something
perhaps more concrete
yeah and let me
try to
address a
very old question a very natural
question in applied mathematics which is
let's imagine that i have a polynomial
multivariate polynomial right and i want
to try to understand whether this
polynomial is not met
right so i have a polynomial in n
variables in here of degree b whatever d
we have to be even and i'm trying to
understand when this polynomial is not
negative whenever i plug in value all
possible variables right and in here i'm
working over the reals
everything that i'm going to say will
extend to other domains but just to make
things simpler and they will not have to
make things difficult i'll just deal
with global non-negativity with problems
so of course if p is quadratic that's
easy i have a quadratic form and check
engine values or actually i just check
if the matrix is positive semi-definite
i'm done but if the degree is greater or
equal than four then that's already in
big heart i give you a quadratic
polynomial we cannot efficiently decide
whether this polynomial is non-negative
or not it's an episode as a function of
number
right there's an obvious i guess cubic
is trivial because if you have a cubic
term all degree so if you have any odd
degree polynomials you go to plus or
minus infinity in some direction
uh
there's an obvious sufficient condition
if i have my polynomial i can write it
as a sum of squares of some other
polynomials q sub i
then obviously this implies this
right
and what i like about i mean what many
people like about this of course is that
you don't have to trust me that i got
this
that this that i'm telling you that my
polynomial is not negative i actually
have a certificate these queues of y's
in there if i just verify that these two
things are exactly the same that's
actually certifying that my polynomial
is not negative it's not as if i were to
run let's say a
quantifier elimination algorithm task is
item or something like this that will
run in your computer for you know three
weeks and you'll not end up telling me
yes or no
and we don't know what i know kind of my
computer that my program was fine or had
a bug or anything like this what
actually happened many of the quantified
elimination software is very buggy
so uh
so what's nice about this again somehow
i know that easy easily verifiable
certificates of negativity and much more
interesting for us
is that this is semi-definite problem
the existence deciding the existence of
such a decomposition whether i give you
a polynomial and checking whether my
polynomial is someone's course or not
it's a semi-definite problem i'll tell
you very briefly how it works
it's not crucial for what they're going
to do i mean it's crucial that it's a
semi-definite problem the details are
not crucial and this is really the
building block i mean everything that we
do afterwards they're just like you know
kind of either dualizing or
putting slight variations on this so if
there's one thing i want to remember is
that whenever you're faced with
non-negativity that's a horrible problem
you're faced with some sort of condition
that's great and we're going to see why
for instance if you care about
entanglement you actually care about
these polynomials even though you may
think that you don't
and this sufficient condition is it like
in typically the case it's always true
we'll talk later
for now the only thing that i'm saying
is that this is a sufficient condition
that in places let me perhaps make a
couple of comments two comments two
cases where you do know that these
things are equivalent
one is of course if p is a quadratic
form
right if p is a quadratic form it's
quadratic then they can value the
composition the factorization cholesky
composition whatever you want will tell
you that this is true
because if you have a quadratic form you
factor it's a sum of squares
the other case is a little bit less
trivial but equally trivial it's a
univariate case if i have a polynomial
in one variable you ride the roads you
play around with the you factor the
polynomial you play around with the
roots and you'll be able to easily write
in the composition of this time and
there's a few other cases hilbert
actually exactly characterizes the cases
or these things
yeah
you can talk about odd degree if you
just look at positive values
something similar you can do just
um
yeah yeah yeah same thing i mean there's
versions of this if i want on negativity
not on rn but i want let's say over a
compact region or a cone or something
like this all this machinery applies
slightly different versions but
essentially the same thing
is it also true for matrix-valued
polynomials uh yes it's essentially true
for matrix value for numbers actually
the univariate case it's uh
ah
it's essentially a result by choice you
know
actually many people reprove that but in
particular
here you're saying that submitted
programs are useful to test
non-negativity because they can test for
i don't directly check this i check this
is there a sense in which this problem
is so universal
is it well it's reducible either i mean
you can go either way right
essentially you're really checking i
mean when you have an sap you really
have a an affine family of polynomials
and you're trying to quadratic
polynomials and you're trying to find
one on that family that it's a sum of
squares perhaps you cannot reduce it to
the case of is this single polynomial
the sum of squares or not but what you
do is you form a pencil or an alpha in
familiar polynomials and you ask each
other one which is the sum of squares in
this funding
and that's actually going to be
important somehow we're going to move in
just a second from the fixed polynomial
case i give you p and you tell me yes or
no to i'll give you an alpha in family
of polynomials and you'll tell me if
there's one that's someone's closer
so again
let me just describe in one slide i i
don't think the details are thoroughly
important but at least i want to give
you a possibility argument why
it's actually proof but
why this checking this condition is a
semi-definite problem so maybe it's easy
very easy right
so
the idea is if i have a polynomial of
even degree b
it's not very difficult to see that my
polynomial is going to be a sum of
squares if and only if i can find the
positives in my definite matrix q
in such a way that i can express my
polynomial as a quadratic form
in
a vector z where c is essentially a
basis for the space of polynomials of
the degree up to the object
right and in particular i can just pick
this polynomial basis
right this basis this monomial basis and
why somehow this is an if an only
because if i have my polynomial and it's
a sum of squares i can just write my sum
of scores as linear functions on this
vector of monomials then when i put
those two things together i get a matrix
q and conversely if i found the matrix
cube that has its property i factor it
and i will get the composition
now
the
only thing that we need to show is that
this condition
they're essentially linear conditions in
q
right and that's easy to see right what
do we oh it's a significant problem what
do we have in here q has to be positive
sigma f and q lives in my cone
what is this really
imagine expanding this expression
what i have in here is a polynomial what
i have in here is another polynomial if
i want these two things to be the same i
will just match coefficients
what are the coefficients on this side
not just linear expressions of the
coefficients of q
so somehow the identity between these
two things they're just linear equations
between the quijs in here and the
coefficients of p that defines a
subspace if i want to find what this is
true or not i have to find the positive
semi-definite matrix on that subspace so
this is exactly a similar problem
if you're concerned about the size of
the semi-definite column how big is q
let me use a board
so that's essentially of size i have all
the monomials of size up to over two so
that's n plus z choose two plus one
which is two remember d is even and this
is actually let's say for fixed d this
is polynomial
it's clear again the main point if you
hand me a polynomial
and you ask me say the sum of course or
not i'll write this in my definition and
you won't write it i'll tell my computer
to write this in my definite problem to
solve it it will tell me yes or no and
if it is it will give me a certificate
it'll be a matrix cue that i can verify
that it's not if it's not true it will
give me a certificate
that this is this polynomial is not sms
watts and we'll talk later about this
kind of discontent
questions
okay
so why do we care about this why do we
care in optimization all these kind of
things because it's a one step to go
from a fixed problem from a fixed
polynomial to optimize it but the only
thing i need to do to really think about
okay let's say that i'm trying to
minimize p i have a polynomial p like
this one algorithm convex whatever and
i'm trying to minimize it
now let me write in a different way
instead of trying to go down in my
polynomial let me try to go up
from the other side
and try to find out whether i can find a
lower bound gamma on my polynomial
and finding the minimum is exactly
finding the largest gamma
in such a way that the polynomial p of x
minus gamma is not negative
right so i have a polynomial i'm trying
to find a minimum i can just take a
constant push it up as much as i can and
as long as this polynomial is not
negative for x that means that p of x is
greater or equal than gamma for all x
right
and of course now
we can go from this non-negativity
condition so i told you they're heavily
and difficult to a condition of this
type
where i try to find the largest gamma
that satisfies that p of x minus gamma
is a sum of squares
and this
we can do
just with the semi-definite problem
exactly the same way that i was doing it
before for a fixed p
why because i play the same game
writing the condition that this has this
quadratic representation and matching
coefficients is going to give me linear
equations between the entries of q
and the coefficients of this polynomial
the coefficients of this polynomial are
linear functions of gamma so i'll have
on the one hand linear functions of q
on the other side linear functions of
gamma these are linear equations and
that's fine i can just maximize gamma
subject to those equations
right so this is again really important
that just in the same way that we do we
deal with a single polynomial p i can
just deal with alpha families i can
think about i have enough i find
subspace of polynomials i'm trying to
find one in that family which is a sum
of squares
right
yep
can you somehow incorporate the gamma
into the barriers yeah gamma is a
decision value yeah exactly so now my
decision variables of my seminal problem
they're simultaneously going to be gamma
and the q survives and i solve for both
at the same time
or let me perhaps take abstract it away
if before i told you that semi-definite
programming was
this idea of i have a cone of matrix and
a subspace now let me just abstract all
this stuff out and just say that now the
problems that i can solve there i have
the cons of sum of squares and i have
subspaces of polynomials
and then i don't care anymore about
semi-definite problem so my definite
problem is under the hood
but the only thing that i care about is
i have a as long as i have alpha in
families of polynomials and i have a
cone of sum of squares i can find points
in these intersections and underneath i
will write them as semi different points
i don't need to ever write a
semi-definite problem if i want to deal
with is this a special case of stp or i
mean because in the particular case
where you take polynomials with
quadratic
forms is amazing so it's not known how
to reduce a general sdp to this form
well if i allow more parameters it is ah
okay okay
it is exactly
good so
this is on the polynomial side let me
just mention very briefly what happens
on the dual i told you that every time
that you have a complex problem there's
a corresponding dual and i just want to
mention it briefly there's a nice oops
interpretation somehow in terms of
moment consistency
so some other question that you want to
add again forget about what i said
before for a second
so the question that i want to answer
for instance in here is imagine that i
actually give you a candidate set of
moments and just to make it easy in
these examples let's imagine that i'm
doing in the univariate case and i'm
interested in the measure for in the
existence of a measure or a product
distribution which is consistent with a
given set of moments right so for
instance in this case i may be
interested in knowing if there's a
priority distribution that has zero
moment one
first moment equal to zero mean equal to
zero second moment equal to two
of course the answer in that case is of
course there is one
right what's an example
so this is just a normalization
condition this is zero mean
and i want variance equal to two so just
pick you know gaussian whatever you pick
the gaussian of
two times this tank or
square root of two than the standard
gaussian and i know that will tell you
that there's a density which is
consistent with toxins
but what happens in this example
right i mean can you find the priority
distribution
whose first moment is one that's just
normalization i want the mean equal to
two and i want the second moment
expected of x square equal to three
probably
essentially causing schwartz yeah but
yeah yeah sure
i could decide my most general
inequality also i believe
yeah so so this will i mean it's easy
way of
saying this for instance if you remember
the variance is always not negative the
variance is the expected value of x
squared minus the expected value of x
squared if you're computing here you'll
have that the variance of this random
variable if it exists it should be equal
to minus 1.
so clearly these numbers are not
consistent with an underlying product of
distribution
right so let me try to and of course
you're seeing what i'm hearing right i
mean you're interested many of you are
interested not in priority distributions
or you should be i guess but or you are
but your particular interest in the
quantum case and somehow if we
understand this case then essentially
the same techniques are going to
generalize
right so why this polynomial stuff that
i was telling you before gives an answer
to this because of course
there's an equivalent characterization
i'll tell you what that star means in a
second or
when instead of moments is actually
they're actually consistent with the
underlying property distribution
essentially the only thing that you need
is that the expected value of all
functions they have to be non-negative
or non-negative functions they have to
be non-negative and i'm working here on
a compact set so that's why i know by er
because polynomials are dense i can just
look at non-negative problems
right
so the point is and let me perhaps make
this a little bit more explicit
instead of myself or that hawk
argument about variance let me try to
explain that argument in a different way
let me say for instance i am smart and
i'm trying to
compute
the expected value under this
whatever probability is if it exists
of something like x minus 2 squared
right and let's compute
what this is going to be by linear and
by expanding this
i don't even know how to expand the
square
so this is minus 4x plus 4.
then i can use linearity of expectations
in here
right because i know that the expected
value of x squared is going to be equal
to three
the expected value of x is going to be
equal to two so this is minus eight plus
four
and this is minus one
right so what happens in here i'm
computing the value of some polynomial
that should be negative and if there's
truly a distribution this should give me
a positive number
but in this case i get something
negative
right so the point is if i were to test
in here
against all possible non-negative
polynomials and i pass this would be
great
i know that at least in compact sets
there has to be a corresponding priority
distribution this is what's called the
truncated bond
sorry
so i would in here
put all
polynomials of this form
and i would require that this is
positive for all polynomials and in here
i'm failing
right
so
somehow what happens in here what's the
way that going to we're producing some
identity approximations of this that
instead of checking against all
polynomials of all degrees we're just
going to ch on all non-negative
polynomials we're somehow only going to
impose the consistency conditions that i
have to produce non-negative values
whenever i compute expectations with
respect to polynomials which are sum of
notes
and somehow this will give me some kind
of outer approximation of this third
diagonal
right
again think of essence
well let's get to quantum finally so
what why should you care about
pornography if all this stuff was a
little bit weird let me tell you that
these are recommend just by essentially
turning the crank this immediately tells
us a very nice way of approximating the
set of several sets right so i think
here i'm looking at bipartite quantum
states we know you know better than me
that you know kind of i'm looking at
essentially convex combinations of
product states and events
yeah i'm looking here as a density
matrix right and of course a question
which is pretty hard is if i give you
state in here and give your wrong i want
to try to understand whether it belongs
to this convex set or not
and notice that complexity doesn't
actually help me in here remember what i
said at the beginning that even if i
start with a complex set if my comic set
is difficult then right now that by
itself doesn't really help me a lot and
of course one may be interested not just
in membership to this set but if you're
not interested in solving uh
some algorithms you may want to optimize
over this set and understand for
instance what happens when you optimize
over this
so what's around this is that it's
fairly natural or essentially
translating what i said before to be so
man we can easily produce nice
approximations for this set and this is
all work that we did like 10 years ago
or something you know with er with
andrew and physical
yeah
okay so what's idea somehow what is a
key
is that if i have a convex set i have
and i have a point which is not on the
set then the obvious way of certifying
at that point is not kanban
right separating hyperplane will tell
you find a separating hyperplane that
puts your state on one side
and puts your uh your several states
your set on the other side
and this picture is nice and wonderful
right i mean it's very easy i have a
complex set i have a point i find it
what's the difficult part in here the
difficult part is given this subspace to
actually check that this set is on that
side
this part is easy right i mean if i have
a soft so it's very fine down inside
the difficult part in here is to verify
that this set is completely contained in
the half space they found by this
right and it's kind of well known let me
i mean many of you know a lot better
than me that there's a perfect
identification between these kind of
separating hyperplanes that leave the
separate states on one side with
something called positive maps
essentially maps that will not make
positive significant matrices into
possibility matrices and i'll tell you
why that's essentially equivalent to
looking at non-negative polynomials of a
certain type what's called by hermitian
polynomials these are going to be
polynomials in two sets of variables
that they're quadratic in one set and
quality
right and again this has a number of
names in you know the
quantum information literature but this
is a well understood or operator theory
and this is kind of
pretty well version
so why somehow what polynomials
appearing here if you're no this is if
you're not exposed to this viewpoint
diagram it may not be obvious in here
that you have somehow some nice
underlying polynomial here it's actually
pretty easy right this idea is if you
want to check whether a hyperplane is
non-negative on the convex set
it's of course enough to just check on
the extreme points of your convex set
right and i can easily parametrize the
extreme points in here
because the extreme point the extreme
points in here are exactly tensor
products of rank one matrices
right and if i write it down if i write
let me just write it this way if i write
the uh
the
yeah the trace the this linear function
applies to a separable state what i'll
get when i expand it is exactly a
polynomial that looks like this which is
bi-quadratic when i fix the axis is
quadratic and y when i fix it y's is
quadratic in x and when i mean quadratic
i mean hermitian in here we're doing the
complex version
right so it really looks like this
for if you give me w
let's say w is your favorite witness in
here i mean just a whole bunch of
numbers
then
the condition that this actually is on
this side
that the set is on this side of my
hyperplane really
boils down to the question of whether
this polynomial is not negative or not
for all values of x and y
so i'm doing i'm sweeping over all
possible extreme points of this and i
have to give it a negative number
of course
at this point i'm setting you up
we cannot do this this is not negativity
what we're going to do or we just want
to write the sum of scores condition on
this and again don't worry about complex
versus three i mean we have some of
hermitian squares same stuff
right
so what happens if we do that this is
clear questions
good so what happens to this this is
great it does give you an approximation
of the set
and of course this is something that
people did know about in somewhat
different form like you know
in
in those terms and for this class of
positive remember i told you there's an
isomorphism between these different
things so somehow the polynomials that
have sum of squares witness they
correspond to something called the
compostable maps in operator theory they
correspond or the sets that those
uh things can detect is something called
ppt state possible partial trace states
in quantum information
so it's great i mean we do get
an approximation of this set but i know
this is we cannot refine this or yet
right the way i present it we just get
another approximation that may be bad or
maybe good we don't know but now is
exactly where the hierarchy parts enter
where not only i'm going to be able to
produce this but i'm going to be able to
produce more and more and more
approximations in here and i'll tell you
in a second how it works
this is clear why we get
remember somehow instead of
identifying all the possible
non-negative polynomials i'm just
identifying the smaller subset which are
the ones that are sums of squares
so in this picture that gives me a
coarser approximation of my set so the
approximation is going to be bigger
it's just duality but i make things
smaller on one side and get
bigger do we make this
stroke don't you have a question yeah
i'm not sure what is what is that
ppt are the ones that when you apply a
partial transpose
you get a positive semi-definite matrix
under states like the ones in here yeah
like the ones in here
that will have uh
yeah exactly
they got seen entangled but
okay so what happens in the
how do we make this stronger
so let me just explain it first because
it's easier in the polynomial case i
mean let me ignore the quantum stuff for
a second but the idea again it's a one
one slide actually one equation which it
says that if i want to put conditions
are somewhere in the middle between p
being sum of squares and p being
non-negative and again for simplicity
let me just work on the sphere let me
make sorry p of homogeneous let me deal
with the homogeneous pronoun right then
something that i can do is just do
something like this i can take my
polynomial and i can multiply it by
something positive let's say in
particular the sum of the squares of my
variables raised to some power k it
doesn't matter
k will matter
so it's again
immediate that this condition is weaker
than this
if pc sum of squares when i multiply it
by another sum of course the product is
also going to be some scores but this
still implies
non-negative
so as i increase in there
this the multiplier the the power k that
i'm using
i'm getting better and better conditions
that approach
this non-negative
and it's not very difficult to show in i
mean in full generality like you know
people have done this right now you know
extremely complicated settings but let's
say on the sphere in the homogeneous
case elementary arguments will tell you
that as k goes to infinity then
essentially we're approaching this code
so if you want in this picture i have
before if you have one set and another
set you're getting
layers and layers between one and the
other and essentially a scale goes to
infinity this fields
so are you saying that any non-negative
polynomial can be uh approximate in the
limit by a product of sum of the squares
ratio of sum of squares i'm sorry but a
ratio of sum of squares right well
sorry i have that this is a sum of
squares so that means that p is a sum of
squares divided by this and that's
essentially what er
art improved right now when he sold
hillary 17
okay so we take that we translate it in
here
before we just looked at
weaknesses for which this expression was
a sum of squares what am i going to do
i'm going to take this i'm going to
multiply it by something
and i'm just going to check whether this
is a sum of course or not i'm going to
be looking for weaknesses of this type
if you do that you'll get nicer classes
in here that closer and closer to the
set of several states
and again as k goes to infinity these
things combination so here's an example
if you want i know this is from the
paper right now i don't remember which
state you're looking or against one of
these difficult states so you look at
the particular weakness you multiply it
by this x x transpose and what you'll
see is that this actually has a nice
decomposition even with integers of this
right
just an example yeah
yeah and certainly for instance if this
is fixed
i can search for a multiplier that's
also a similar problem
if i fix this if i fix my weakness
then i can actually search for the best
multiplier in here
yeah so in general what you do is you
just use this
i mean certainly the things that we
defined would just fix like you know
kind of that multiply to that yeah i
mean in in the stuff that we did we just
fix it to this
okay
so let me mention very briefly uh
the dual
an interpretation that also i think many
of you are familiar with which is
somehow like before i told you there's a
dual story there's also a dual story in
here if you don't like entanglement
witnesses and you'd rather think just
directly in terms of the state
is that
you know
is
the
is the particular choice of the excise
square to the case
you know you could you could optimize it
but like can it vary by a lot in terms
of the degree or is there uh
that's something that we don't even in
the in the general case we don't
understand very well even in the
polynomial case there are certainly
cases where if you pick that very very
carefully you can get away with
certificates of law degree if you use
something universal like this then i
know kind of you may have to somehow
make things longer yeah i mean higher
levels and that's a huge difference and
we don't know examples or there's a huge
difference
well well look i mean the fact that
deciding separability is np hard right
or you know uh optimizing over separable
stages and be hard sort of tells us that
there must be some cases where k has to
increase of course yeah yeah yeah yeah
no but but rather right
yeah but
that's a different question okay all
right
in here oh an arbitrary positive
polynomial if you know any positive
thing to put in there but then you have
to have a certificate that's actually
positive
if you actually want to prove something
yeah um does this have anything to do
with the hierarchy of k extendable
states of course
like for you know for pptp
well you get it you get the class of
wheat i mean it's hard to characterize
it other than in terms of this but right
now they're essentially the things that
have certificates of this type that you
only need to multiply it once by
something until they become a sounds of
permissions works yeah it's somehow
tautological we don't have an intrinsic
definition of what do they do
it would be nice to see
right
pablo is an accurate characterization
you want to
witness normally like a measurement on
systems a b
that
uh but it should be one that if you
write m on a b
plus m on a b prime
then that resulting operator should be
positive semi-definite uh yeah so that's
kind of like essentially what will
happen here right but i mean when you do
the extension but if you say on the on
the first level what are the witnesses
well those are the decomposable
witnesses but then if you say what are
the witnesses that correspond to a
higher level of the hierarchy would they
be the ones that that you know
satisfy that property i just said uh
or no
i'm not sure okay i think yeah
yeah are there entangled states that you
reach for no k or or is it really
conversion so well no so we don't get
you don't get in general you get the
declaration of this we'll give you the
hold home sorry you get that the closure
of this or you take the union of this
for our case yeah and you take the
closure of this and that will give you
the cell so the intersection right
you'll get the set of several sets so
essentially if i would run my algorithm
forever with increasing case i would at
some point yeah
it would ingrain already
yeah for anything like that yeah it's a
complete hierarchy i mean that's
exciting
so what's the dual viewpoint again like
i told you before you have consistency
of margin that's in the
in the in the classical case what
happens in the quantum case is the story
about symmetric state extensions right
so instead of thinking of my original
bipartite state
i may think okay if my state is actually
separable then i can actually write down
explicitly some kind of extension of my
state to more parties right or somehow
the property that this state will have
is that it's going to be symmetric
between these two parties let's say two
in here or k in general and also when i
do a partial trace over all these other
components i get back the original state
and it turns out that you can decide
that separate states will always have
these extensions entangled states cannot
have these extensions to an infinite
number of parties or sorry to a
sufficiently large number of parties and
this is under if you check the existence
of the conditions sometimes the only
thing that it's involved in there are
either linear equations or semi-definite
conditions so this is
a semi-definite problem and in fact it's
exactly the dual of the stuff that i
described in the previous one
so somehow this makes very clear the
picture that i was saying before it's
really about consistency of a certain
type right in here it's consistency case
match
sorry yeah it's exactly the same
yeah so if i want in here extensions
okay parties then that is
yeah exactly this is where you see the
sum of the x y squared essentially
because i exactly copied this in the
other components yeah if i were to pick
something different in there then i'm
doing something different in here and i
cannot quite understand i mean
i don't know what it is in the
progressive case i don't quite know
exactly what will happen here
essentially it would correspond to
normalizing the cone in a different way
i mean what they're really doing is
you're making this compact by taking a
section the sum of the x y is equal to
one and then you're taking a different
compact section of the same column which
i think will be like a different
normalization condition but again i
don't know the exact concept
uh
very quickly the three slides i have two
minutes i have so one is of course this
should ring a bell and it's exactly
somehow the equivalent of the classical
definitive theorems in probability
definitely theorems and probability will
tell you that if you have a sequence of
random variables that's infinitely
exchangeable then that's equivalent to
being a mixture of ids
and somehow it's underlying gold stories
some finite versions of that that were
worked out by the diacons and freeman
and somehow the quantum versions of
these both infinite and infinite that
will work out by a number of people and
in particular something very nice that
comes out of all this work is that you
can actually something that we suddenly
didn't do which is it gives you a nice
way of quantifying how well do things do
as a function of k
so if you want to know how well your
approximation approximating this sets
and you're giving a certain error and
you want to understand what k you need
and think of k again either as a degree
of this exponent of this multiplier or
the number of copies then these kind of
theorems will actually tell you how you
should pick k if you want to guarantee
that this will happen and there's a
number of different results i decided
not to put anywhere they really vary in
terms of how you pick norms if you're
measuring things in one norm to normally
loss is norm and of course fernando and
i guess a number of other people are
kind of
who you should ask for these kind of
things
so in the one minute that i have let me
just tell you that you know kind of how
this generalized or generalizes for
instance for the non-communicative case
and the idea is it's exactly the same
you don't need to even think about this
at least if you want to write the
corresponding conditions if you want to
analyze them of course you have to work
but if you just want to understand what
happens it's exactly the same thing what
do you have now if you have a
non-commutative polynomial
you can have non-commutative polynomials
in operators or matrices if you want
there's a natural notion of positivity i
want this to be positive
there's a notion of sum of squares i
want to have a quadratic representation
of a certain type this immigration
problem that you write is exactly the
same you write this you write monomials
you expand you match coefficients and
essentially what you want to understand
is how to approximate this kind of
nested comb complex bodies that we saw
last time right i mean there's a
polynomial of classical correlations
there's a quantum convex set and there's
a no signal in polytube this is easy
this is combinatorially hard it's
essentially cut politic and this is a
thing that we don't understand very well
which is exactly the kind of things that
you want to optimize over when you want
to compute values of gains and what you
will do in this case for instance if you
want to compute the value of let's say
some game of this type and this is in
the paper by andrew and young ben toner
and
stephanie vader
so what you're really trying to do is to
maximize a function that looks like this
over a's and b's a and b's and there are
your the podms of the two players so
instead of requiring that this
polynomial being a negative i mean a
spectral value
an eigenvalue condition on this is
essentially a polynomial being bounded
below by gamma you just try to find a
certificate
that that thing is a sum of scores and
if you actually increase the degree of
the multipliers you get exactly the kind
of semi-definite hierarchies that they
obtained or dually the ones that uh
navas quests are seen on piranha they
obtain in this case
it's exactly the same picture
what's the tricky part these arguments
which i have to say i don't really
understand very well on the question of
finite dimensionality right whether you
can achieve the things in find the the
optimal values in finite dimensions and
i don't think these things are
yet tell us anything about that i mean
perhaps there's a way of extracting
something from primary dual solutions
but i
i really should wrap up shave this out
we have a uh
this nice
book with within with a number of people
underneath with all this stuff at the
beginning
you don't have to buy it you can duck
you can search it on on the web and
you'll find it
but the idea is that again somehow
there's a very nice uh way of just
approaching this siam will not be happy
if i say this but that's fine
actually no they they allowed us to do
this so i'm not doing anything wrong
either morally or later
and the idea is again somehow if we just
focus on these sum of squares type
conditions i mean many of these things
they really come very naturally i mean
it's either positivity conditions on
computative variables or non-competitive
variables and the techniques are exactly
the same nothing really
becomes
thank you
any questions
yes it does so there's a very nice
result by
unforgetting a plenum
oh i didn't write it yeah
it wasn't plenty more squares yeah
worried yeah
it's question warrior they show that the
convergence rate that you get
is actually better when you when you
include when you include the ppt
conditions then if you just look at the
at the symmetric extension condition
essentially it goes from something like
hello so like one over l to one over l
squared
in navasquez
they go from one over k if you don't
impose a positive condition to one over
k squared
the equivalent source again between
symmetry and um
exchangeability i mean exchangeability
and subsystem is also so so
so this theorem fails it's true in the
diminished setting but based on the
market
so they're very verbals which are which
are sort of getting more and more
independent over their tail
but they're not exchangeable anymore
right yeah yeah yeah in here essentially
what you use or what provides a
completeness are these results by the
helton and mccollum so they prove the
a non-commutative version of the
positive characters that kind of applies
in this sense yeah but that's yeah okay
just to make sure i understood the last
part of what you said for the field
theoretic value of a non-local game you
can approximate it sort of from above
like converge on it but you can't just
approximate it because you can't
get lower bounce is that correct the
question what's not clear in here is
so the way that this formulation works
is working from below right so it's and
what it's not clear is whether you're
actually converging to the true value
whether there's a finite dimensional
strategy that will produce that value
you're producing lower bounds okay but
it's i mean
we don't know apparently again i'm not
an expert on this that we can achieve
this one's in final time
right exactly
way back in your first slide or
something you made a comment today
asking how seriously i think you're
making an analogy i think to the
relaxation to use the crypto would be
broken basis relaxation
and
finance fields and everything so just so
how so essentially what you do i mean
it's very similar to what you're doing
in here instead of looking at quadratic
equations you're linear right sorry at
polynomial equations you linearize you
introduce new variables for you know
finite products and then you just treat
them as linear equations in this now
you're doing exactly the same thing the
difference that you also impose the
positivity conditions are coming from
this
and the problem is of course we cannot
do this over final trips
at least i don't know
but i mean conceptually it's exactly the
same now you know again if you just
linearize no you know the point is in
here over reals we know more valid
constraints that are true and those are
coming from that
question so you in fact refer to the
argument
so does anything here so if i start with
a rational function that i want to show
so does any of this
so this is much more general than what i
described essentially an actually semi
algebraic problem you can write this
kind of relaxations as long as it's a
major right you can do it they know
these kind of things
okay there are no further questions
let's thank pablo again